[Music]
she was one
of the special guests at their wedding
and now oprah has secured the interview
that everybody wanted
the sussex is deciding to go public
about why they had to step away from
royal life
described as an intimate conversation
with the queen of talk shows
the topics on the table include their
move to america
how megan felt stepping into royal life
and how she's handling the public
pressure
as their family grows all potentially
uncomfortable viewing for the palace
no matter what anybody says no matter
what the intention is
this is a couple that have just come out
of a a very difficult
court case where they've been saying
that they need their privacy
and within days they're talking about
tail or interviews so
it just gives a suggestion of hypocrisy
that's what they're going to be accused
of
um and i think it's just a mistake
after the fall out from princess diana's
panorama interview in 1995 and
prince charles publicly talking about
his affair
the royals have steered clear of giving
very personal interviews
but harry and megan have already shown
they're not afraid to tell the world how
they're feeling
during their tour of south africa they
made it clear they didn't feel supported
and after they announced last year they
wanted a financially independent life
harry went against the palace line to
say
he wasn't happy the decision that
i have made for my wife and i to step
back
is not one i made lightly it was so many
months of talks
after so many years of challenges and i
know i haven't always gotten it right
but as far as this goes there really was
no other option
almost 12 months since they left and we
know that discussions have been going on
behind the scenes about how this new way
of working has been going for them
and for the royal family but the fact
they've decided to do this interview may
be a suggestion
they haven't been entirely happy with
how that's all been playing out
and this is therefore their chance to
tell their side
of the story
their friend oprah isn't a surprising
choice
but doing the interview is a huge step
no longer working royals they didn't
have to tell the palace
but it appears they didn't tell their
family either
who it seems like the rest of us will
have to watch on the 7th of march
and see how far the sussexes have
decided to go
[Applause]
[Music]
rhiannon mills sky news